a superhero movie wouldn't be a
superhero movie without a good fights or
really nasty villain but sometimes
things can get a little out of hand from
gross out violence or the scariest bad
guys in the universe these are the
superhero movie moments that went too
far
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is a
franchise meant for all ages so there
haven't been a whole lot of disturbing
moments during the series long run but
this just means that when things do get
gross those scenes really stick out take
Ant Man for example in Scott Lang's
first movie l sing the villainous
businessman Darren cross turns an
unsuspecting colleague into a pulsating
puree of organic jelly
it's especially upsetting since poor old
Frank is portrayed as a relatively
level-headed guy he's a high-ranking
executive of Pym technologies and when
crust starts talking about his yellow
jacket program Frank says they should
hit the brakes on the whole microscopic
murder suit thing but cross isn't the
kind of guy who takes no for an answer
so the super villian corners Frank in
the company restroom and sub support
dude with a shrink ray he subsequently
reduced to a bubbling blob of goo and
promptly wiped up and flushed down the
toilet for good measure this scene could
have been a lot worse
two-in-one anews take stole actually
tastes the slime before flushing it down
the drain oh and then there's this come
on man
Thanos might just be the worst dad in
the MCU which let's be honest is really
saying something you really need to grow
up
the mad seitan is incredibly abusive
towards adopted children especially poor
nebula who he's been torturing for
decades in infinity war he goes one
further practically tearing her into
pieces when he gets his hands on her
but things grow even grimmer when Thanos
captures his favorite wayward daughter
Gamora after kidnapping her Thanos takes
Kimora to for Mia in search of the soul
stone when they arrive a fellow's
learned that if you want to acquire the
gem you've got to sacrifice the thing
you love most
at first Gamora thinks this is hilarious
because obviously Thanos doesn't love
anybody
you probably remember what happens next
just remember that's only a few minutes
ago spider-man was fighting star-lord
and Thor was cracking joke to the
talking raccoon now you've got gamora's
broken body haloed by blood it's a heck
of a shift in tone with its grotesque
flipper hands and terrifying jagged
teeth there's no villain more disturbing
than the penguin this ball of blubber
spends his days living in the sewers of
Gotham City and uses black sludge from
practically every orifice in Batman
Returns the Penguins got big plans with
the help of evil businessman Max Schreck
he intends to become Gotham's new mayor
but if he's going to win over voters
he'll need a total makeover after all
when he first waddles into his campaign
headquarters he's chowing down on raw
fish and wearing the world's dirtiest
pajamas fortunately however he's also
got a team of image consultants who
cheerfully offer him tips and that's
when one poor sap makes a crack about
his new boss and a lot of reflective
surfaces down penguin reacts about as
well as you could hope honestly it's
pretty horrifying but hey as far as
political campaigns go probably not the
worst start in history The Joker has
always had a flair for the dramatic and
he puts his showmanship on full display
in The Dark Knight in Christopher
Nolan's classic superhero movie the
Clown Prince of Crime is a Kaos loving
terrorist with a very very complicated
plan to get rid of Batman and like he
saves himself if you're good at
something why do it for free instead of
straight up killing the Caped Crusader
The Joker offers as murderous services
to the city's criminals for a hefty fee
he makes his pitch at a mob boss meeting
but these gangsters aren't wild about
working with the Joker since he's been
robbing the
one particular gangster an angry fellow
named gamble wants a joker dead and
orders a crony to pull the clown's head
off but that's when the Joker decides
it's time for a magic trick and one of
cinema's most notorious killings and
soos I'm gonna make this pencil
disappear pretty terrible right but
that's the Joker for you for this guy
killing dudes with writing utensils it's
just one great big joke and that's what
makes him such a messed up monster while
the MCU is mostly a squeaky-clean series
of movies things do get a little bit
edgy in the guardians of the galaxy
franchise there's an infamous crack
about Jackson Pollock paintings of
course as well as a one scene when the
movies heroes gleefully wipe out an
entire ship full of space pirates but
it's all in good fun until tazer face
leads his mutiny anyway in guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 the monstrous ravager
taser face is tired of the way is bossy
on dude as business so he turns a
Ravager crew against that captain and
that's when things get dark some other
ravages are still loyal to yondu but
they're quickly dragged kicking and
screaming to the ship's airlock they're
then tossed into the void of space where
they suffocate and freeze to death were
still the mutinous ravages are enjoying
this a little too much laughing and
cheering as their victims die it's all
incredibly ghoulish and the things got
even nastier a little later when they
send their attention to poor baby Groot
the mutinous pirates laugh ahem pour
beer on his head and physically abuse
this adorable sapling all in all this
sequence is genuinely upsetting and well
the MCU it's filled with villainous
monsters they don't get much more
sadistic than taser face and his crew
Logan is a blood-soaked near Western
that ups the gore on the previous x-men
movies all the while dealing with the
emotional impact of taking a human life
Joey there's no living for the killing
there's no going back
right Iran's brand ban stinks and that's
something that Wolverine has to deal
with every day he's killed a whole lot
of people over the years and even if
they deserved it the movie makes it
clear that killing still takes a piece
of your soul never is that clearer in
Logan than in the movies Hotel sequence
on the run from the deadly rivers Logan
Laura and Charles Xavier holed up in a
casino by the dementia addled professor
eggs have a massive seizure as Xavier
convulses he sends out telepathic waves
across the casino paralyzing almost
everyone including a band of reverts who
have burst into his room
the only one strong enough to move are
Logan and Laura and thus Wolverine drags
himself down a hallway he decides it's
time to whip out the adamantium claws
because everything appears so slowed
down the audience sees her Rivas react
at a snail's pace as the claws come
crashing towards their scales but
there's nothing they can do about it
you can't blame Logan for feeling a
little haunted considering director
David F Sandberg cut his teeth in the
world of horror it's not much of a
surprise that Shazam features some of
the freakiest cinematic supervillains to
date the seven deadly sins
these guys are monstrous demons complete
with horns fangs and wickedly long
tongues they were encased in stone by an
ancient wizard but when dr. thaddeus
sivana shows up he unleashes the demons
and plays host to their satanic party
possessed by the sins savannah has all
sorts of crazy powers so what's the
first thing he does with his newfound
gifts well get revenge on his family of
course his father and brother both
influential businessman have been
emotionally abusing him for decades
quite literally filled with wrath
sivanna heads over to their company
office strolls into a boardroom meeting
and unleashes has seven new friends
the hungry demons gobble up everybody in
the room and for the terrified
executives desperately tried to escape
there's no getting away from savanah in
the sense the promotional material
fishes am promised a goofy good time but
nobody was expecting a bunch of demons
to devour a room full of people but this
shocking scene does a fantastic job of
setting the stakes proving that savanah
isn't here to play and that billy batson
a better get his act together real fast
Sam Raimi is a king of slapstick horror
and while spider-man 2 isn't exactly a
horror movie it does contain one
terrifying scene that holds its own
the directors most messed up moments it
all starts after a science experiments
gone wrong dr. Otto Octavius is ready to
unveil a fusion reactor that will
finally create renewable energy but he
can't handle the fuel with his bare
hands so he constructs for mechanical
arms and straps those bad boys onto his
back
luckily the experiment is a total
success of tavius is hailed as a hero
and the world becomes a happier place
all right not really everything goes
wrong pretty much immediately the chip
that controls the arms is shattered and
octavius's arms take over his mind the
explosive experiments also knocks
Octavius out cold and fuses the
tentacles to his spine so after
everything calms down his unconscious
body is wheeled into an operating room a
team of surgeons prepare to hack the
arms off and that's when things go wrong
again like a squid possessed by Satan
the arms was around the room slashing
and grabbing and dragging doctors to
their deaths and the entire time Doc Ock
is totally unconscious unaware the
tentacles on his back have turned the
operating room into a massacre before
joining the MCU with James Gunn dabbled
in the superhero genre with super a 2010
flick that's both hilarious and
nauseating the story follows a
short-order cook named Frank who feels
like a complete loser especially after
his wife runs off with a depraved drug
dealer devastated Frank decides to
become the superhero Crimson bolts and
along with his homicidal sidekick Balti
he unleashes hell on all the local
crooks he can find super is not for the
faint of heart and things got even worse
in the final fight scene when Dwight
Schrute goes full-on Travis Bickle
determined to get his wife back Crimson
bolt attacks Kevin Bacon's lair and the
ensuing scene is well it's actually
incredibly upsetting
Ellen Page gets her face shut off
Michael Rooker gets his head introduced
to a brick fireplace and to capital
laughs a Frank stabs his arch-nemesis to
death slowly one stab at a time it's not
exactly Captain America based on the Lum
Marco graphic novel Watchmen makes a
point of analyzing the deviance and the
losers who were flowing capes and skin
fight suits and the craziest of the
bunch is Rorschach an impending
vigilante who lives by a very violent
code working outside the law Rorschach
is investigating the death of several
super colleagues when he's arrested
tossed in jail obviously this isn't the
best place for a crime fighter to be
especially since Rorschach put a lot of
these guys behind bars
and sure enough ordering a nasty prison
riot some of his old friends come to pay
him a visit big figure is a diminutive
gangster with some seriously oversized
goons and they're all in prison thanks
to the fedora wearing Watchmen big
figure wants revenge of course and
orders one of his thugs to saw open
Rorschach cell and cut the dude to
pieces however when henchman number one
reaches through the bars Rorschach
breaks his thumbs and ties his arms
together preventing big figure from
soaring through the lock but big figure
is a really loyal to his lackeys and he
orders henchman number 2 to cut off the
guy's arms so they can reach the lock
the guy tied to the cell begs and pleads
for his life but henchman number 2 takes
a buzzsaw and slices through his buddy's
arms leaving him with two gory stumps
naturally Rorschach isn't fazed by any
of this
but you probably can't say the same for
the audience check out one of our newest
videos right here Plus even more looper
videos buy your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]